make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay what's going on guys this is rob
and we're continuing deceased uh and in
this one we are picking up with part
five or whatever part this happens to be
but the the dc's dead planet event right
so uh in this video we pick up with john
constantine and dr fate while they are
heading into or really just
constantine heading into one of the
doors of the tower of fate and the funny
thing about this is that he actually
won't let dr fate end right because it's
kind of like this door's closed uh
it's a private meeting home slice you
gotta stay out here
and so once he actually gets inside you
know because there's not really a
doorknob readily available for dr fate
to use
constantine kind of spawns one goes
inside and then shuts it and of course
the door not vanishes but we end up
finding out inside this room
is etrigan and etrigan of course always
speaking in rhymes kind of follows up
with the previous discussion they had
about trigon coming to earth and that
when when constantine kind of asked for
an update here right like
what's the update like how long until
trigan gets here the response of etrigan
is you have three days
you have three days until trigan makes
his move and he comes to earth
and so it's kind of like okay now the
other part of this is that the green
uh that's being used by you know the
ultra wealthy and powerful in order to
spawn
you know vegetables and things like that
it's still kind of pissing off swamp
thing right so that needs to be dealt
with but the immediate threat as far as
constantine is concerned
is to focus on essentially taking out
the uh taking out trigon or at least
trying to find some way to defeat trigon
which is a tall order
even for the most powerful of beings
inside of dc comics let alone just john
constantine right and so he takes a
cloak of ragman which as we know has the
ability to absorb the souls of other
people
and then leaves from there he basically
assembles what is for the most part a
strike team and this strike team
of course is more or less being led by
batman by damien wayne alongside uh
rose the daughter of deathstroke in
addition to jason todd and a few others
now the funny thing about this is that
rose and jason todd had actually gotten
married
i don't like that this just kind of
happened off panel i think it would have
been cool to actually see
how rose and jason todd really began to
hit it off how that romance really began
to blossom and how the two of them ended
up getting married it really kind of
seemed to be rose's clairvoyance that
led to like okay we're gonna get married
because
i saw it happening so let's just do it
now and then they did so
i don't really know but the important
thing here is that what they end up
doing
is transitioning you know to nanda
parbat to basically you know
well really constantine using the green
to get there and then of course the rest
of them using a portal to access it but
with nanda parbot you know essentially
the league of assassins more or less
being infected here
uh what you also have is just this
colossal army and the the issue that you
really have
really kind of comes from damian wayne
which is really designed to sort of show
how far he's come
in the time that he took on the mantle
of batman versus when we first saw him
in the sense that he maintains the
ideology of bruce wayne that if there's
a cure here that we cannot kill these
people right if there is a definitive
cure and that cure resides
in the realm of the new gods or whatever
it is they have to do to get it they
can't kill everybody here because
technically they'd be killing people who
could be saved and so it's it's a bit
murky here because in my mind i would be
like
no i mean you could save them but if you
guys die the world's gonna be destroyed
by trigon and so it's like hey look i'm
sorry all you innocent
people but our need is greater than
yours so you got to die right i mean we
won't
intentionally kill you but if you run up
on us and you get in our way then we're
going to do you in that's that's what i
would do
but i'm also a little more hardcore
right i mean i'm a little more in the
eye
in the philosophical views that the ends
do justify the means
depending on what the ends are right and
so because of that you end up seeing
rose who basically again uses their kind
of clairvoyance to sort of know where
she needs to go in order to
to get to where they need to be and then
basically knocks on the door and you end
up being met by
boston brand by dead man right he has of
course the ability to possess the bodies
of others and so as he opens the door
the forces of nanda parbat come pouring
out and then of course start attacking
all these these undead people who were
here right basically kind of you know
taking care of them while constantine
heads inside nanda parbot meets with
ramakrishna and
and basically accesses the spear of
destiny now ramakrishna
is a being out there um who represents
karma more or less so she is in fact a
literal goddess and so killing her
isn't necessarily something that can be
done easily the most powerful of beings
out there can
but not everybody can right i mean she
is for the most part an immortal person
she could live on forever but the spear
of destiny is actually designed to kill
a god right now it doesn't mean he could
stab her once and then she's dead
but the problem with this is that she
won't let him take it this is very much
like a holy figure right this is a holy
thing the spear of destiny you can't
just
take it and walk away with it it doesn't
work that way and so because of the fact
that john constantine knows this he does
the only thing that he can do he stabs
ramakrishna
and then takes the spear of destiny for
himself now like immediately after that
dead man shows up like my god what did
you do ghost who attacked constantine
and constantine
absorbs dead man into the ragman cloak
so now boston bran is gone
right he's dead he's effectively gone
here i mean i guess not dead in the
traditional sense but my all standards
of measurement is dead now as far as
ramakrishna goes she'll survive right i
mean she can't really be killed by that
but everybody's kind of pissed a
constantine but his whole his whole
stance here is
look guys dragon's coming to earth and
he's going to kill us we don't really
have
time to play this game of but it's a
mean thing to do
constantine it's just such a mean thing
to do we don't have time for that right
like this is the time to put up or shut
up and your morals are going to be
questioned here
if you can't handle that leave right
like this is not the time
for wine eye naivety and the idea of
well we can save everybody's life is the
time to do what you got to do so if you
can't man up then go play with the
kitties while the rest of us do what
needs to be done right
this is a time for men it's a time for
adults it's a time for grown women
to do what needs to be done in this
situation and so following that they end
up transitioning to the rock of eternity
which is amazing right they get through
here of course you got the seven deadly
sins you know all that kind of stuff but
as soon as they get in and as soon as
they get to where they're supposed to be
they're immediately met by by freddie
freeman right by captain marvel jr who
literally goes on a rampage and just
starts attacking
all of them now in that process you've
also got the old wizard shazam
who seems to be infected with the very
least is just kind of living this this
terrible horrible fate and so what you
end up having is rose who kills the old
wizard shazam by stabbing him through
the head with a sword when that happens
and you end up having like the staff of
the old man which is what they were
there for
that uh the cassandra kane is the one
who picks it up and cassandra kane
becomes the new shazam now the funny
thing about this is that with freddie
freeman freaking out the way he is her
power is equal to his but one of the
things that we're immediately told here
is that freddie freeman was just an
orphan kid who got the power of shazam
he's not a fighter cassandra kane has
been fighting her entire life and she
was trained
by the single greatest fighter in the
entirety of dc comics this is literally
a girl
born to kill you know who she was born
and bred to kill anybody in her past
her with the power of shazam fighting
off against freddie freeman it wasn't
even a contest freddie freeman was dead
before he even knew what happened the
problem with this is that when freddy
freeman
initially launched his attack he
immediately went for jason todd and
crashed him into a wall and when that
happened he
killed jason todd right so jason todd is
now dead which totally sucks and so once
they all basically end up getting back
there of course they bring jason todd's
body
batman freaks out and he's like you know
this this is ridiculous right like you
got you got you got jason todd killed
here but at the end of the day
it was a small price to pay to save the
earth right i mean that's kind of the
nature of the beast if these people out
here really can
be saved then jason todd jason todd's
death while tragic
pales in comparison to the billions of
lives out there that could be spared
it's simple utilitarianism the needs of
the many outweigh the needs of the few
and so what you end up getting is this
kind of disembodied voice it tells
john constantine you deserve that right
you deserve to get punched in the face
the way that you did by batman because
of what you've done
and and we end up finding out this voice
is coming from jim corrigan
this voice is coming directly from the
spectre and when you have constantine
talking to him
the specter is the ghost of wrath thinks
that you know things i deserve to be
punched in the face
huge deal and he basically tells him
like you're holding an object that could
end
even me right that's concerning and i
can stop you
from what you're doing constantine and
constantine's response is
you could right you're the spirit of
vengeance you could kill me and
everybody here but ask yourself
and ask yourself this question if i
would go to these lengths to attain
weapons that could kill gods don't you
think there's a reason why
and corrigan kind of looks at him for a
second and says yeah you're right and
then leaves
that's kind of the funny thing here and
this is something that i actually like
about what's going on with with dc's
dead planet technically
jim corgan could just purify the earth
right and just be done with it he could
purify all these people he could kill
them all
and their souls would pass on to the
dragon's realm and trigon wouldn't
really have any reason to invade earth
anymore right it could all just be ended
by spectre but it's cool that he's not
it's cool that that this is not being
invoked by uh by dc because it would be
lazy
and it would be an easy way out it would
be super lazy if he's just like if he's
like wipes his head weighs his hand and
everybody's dead
done day saved thanks jim corgan let's
meet up for beers and hot dogs you know
and that's that's it right it would just
be kind of lame right it would it would
be it would be pretty lame but i love
what dc's doing here now if i'm a
betting man
i think jim corgan is going to have a
much bigger role to play in the events
of deceased but for now
it's cool to see that he's not being
used as an easy way out with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
cork if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like now we'll
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you